hey you guys flickers of fear time again
this is my little movie review show
now
i'd like to try to do at least one
giallo movie like every month because
you know anybody that's been watching uh
this show for any length of time knows
how much i really really like uh the
italian sub genre
known as the jello film and i'm really
trying to i've seen like a bunch of them
i went on kind of a kick a few years ago
and i saw a bunch of them including this
one uh but i've been re-watching
revisiting them a lot lately because
i've been wanting to do a lot of them
for my show now a few weeks ago i can't
remember how long it was but i did
another sergio martino
giallo movie uh called your vice is a
locked room and only i have the key and
i mentioned on that one
that the title for that movie
even though it doesn't really have
anything to do with the plot of the
movie actually came from this movie
which was an earlier film and actually
the first
giallo film not the first film overall
but the first yellow film that sergio
martino had directed this is the strange
vice of mrs ward now in a lot of ways
it's kind of similar to your vice as a
locked room um even though you know the
title makes a lot more sense uh you know
it's a jello film it's kind of like you
know with all the red herrings and
everything like that
and it also stars uh ed vig finnish uh
who was in the other movies so she's
been like a [ __ ] ton of uh giallo movies
including many of sergio martino's ones
she was also in all the colors of the
dark which i will probably get to
eventually because i really really like
that one because it's has kind of like a
psychedelic sort of feel to it so this
one i will say that i actually liked
this one more than your vice is a locker
room but not as much as all the colors
of the dark this one it's really really
hard to talk about without spoiling it
because this one is like super super
twisty turny and has like a bunch of
crazy
uh not entirely believable plot twists
but plot twists that you probably won't
see coming so you know that's that's
something right there but i will say
that it's kind of like and this is not
um a ding on it at all because i didn't
mind this but the first part of it it's
about an hour and 40 minutes in total
the first part of it is um a little bit
slow and it takes a while to
kind of get where it's going and a lot
of the twists and turns and stuff happen
like right near the end like in the last
20 minutes of the movie so if you're
watching it and you kind of feel like
man this isn't going anywhere or
anything like that just sit tight
because
uh some crazy [ __ ] is gonna happen at
the end like i said i don't know
it's not entirely believable but it's
pretty original in the sense that
i had seen it before like i saw it a
long time ago but i didn't remember who
the killer was
so the whole time i'm always trying to
like figure it out and there's not
there's a lot of red herrings in this
but there's not
a lot of
suspects this one doesn't have like a
huge cast of suspects there's really
only three or four main ones and really
any of them just like in most yellow
movies it could be any one of them
because they're all kind of shady
or they all they all have like similar
motivations so you know you know it's
gonna be one of them but
uh i didn't actually remember how this
went like i remembered it a little more
like as i was watching it but yeah so uh
this movie is on shutter at the moment i
believe it's also on to be uh for free
there's a actually if you go on to be
i'm actually quite amazed there's uh
there's a large large number of uh
giallo movies on there not you know some
some not of the best ones but there's
like some really good like you know
second tier b squad uh jala movies in
there so if there's some on there that
you haven't seen you might want to check
out too because they actually do have
quite a bit shutter also has a very
large uh collection of them including a
lot of sergio martino films a lot of you
know mario bava a lot of that kind of
stuff they added like a [ __ ] ton of them
not too long ago which is what i was
happy about because i wanted to do a lot
of them for this show and it was nice to
have them on shutter so i could watch
them without ads so this movie came out
in 1971.
as i mentioned uh ed beach fenich she's
a french actress i think i mentioned
that previously just an amazingly
amazingly beautiful woman she's like a
beautiful like expressive face and she
plays uh the main character now i will
note uh this is called so like i said
it's called the strange vice of mrs ward
but ward has an h at the end uh the
reason for that it's not they weren't
trying to be exotic or anything like
that i guess when this movie came out
there was a woman
who an italian woman whose name was mrs
ward you know without the h and she
thought that this movie
because of the strange vice implicit in
the title
she thought it would make her look bad
or people would associate her with the
movie so she was like threatening to sue
so basically sergio martino had to like
add an h at the end real quick and like
change all the marketing materials i'm
presuming uh so that woman wouldn't get
upset and have her reputation ruined so
you know so there's that so people were
like even complaining about that back in
the 70s i will note too this was
released in the u.s under a different
title i believe it's called blade of the
ripper i'm not sure if they cut anything
out this isn't a super gory movie it's
some of the kills are pretty violent but
it's not kind of like because you know
how
you know a lot of dario argento movies
he's almost kind of he's fetishizing uh
the murders and fetishizing the violence
so it's like sometimes you know you get
like a knife it's like right in a heart
like you know an open chest and he's
just like really like into showing that
i feel like he's that's kind of his
thing uh jealous do tend to be very
violent like i said there's a lot of
violence against women you know it's
usually uh bladed weapons you know this
one has uh you know a lot of them have
knives this one actually has a straight
razor so you do see people getting cut
up with a straight razor that's about it
it's not
you know it's not this ridiculous it's
not like you know deep red or some of
dario argento's movies where like you
know our limbs get cut off and blood
sprays everywhere and stuff like that
it's a lot more subdued than that
so i don't know if like the us release
originally when this came out in the
early 70s i don't see any reason why
could have been
cut for violence however
uh i'm sure it was probably cut for
nudity because just like sergio
martino's other movie that i talked
about your vice is a locked room there
is a [ __ ] ton of nudity in this i don't
i wouldn't call this a sleazy movie um
it definitely does have some scenes of
nudity and some sex scenes that probably
didn't need to be in there but i do kind
of feel like a lot of these european
sort of movies they put that in there
for various other countries
uh because you know as the us was kind
of puritanical about it particularly at
the time but other european countries
were a lot more open with it so they
said well we're just going to like film
all this nudity boobies and all this
other stuff put all that in there and
then whichever country we're putting out
in more or less nudity we can we can cut
it as i'm so so that's i think why
there's so many scenes of nudity there's
so many sex scenes in this but i will
note in the movies defense even though
there are a few scenes and i'll get to
that in a minute where it really didn't
need to be in there like they didn't
need to be nudity but i will defend it
because one of the kind of key plot
points of this movie
is a sexual fetish or like a sexual
desire that uh mrs ward has so in a way
it's like pretty legit that it's all in
there and like i said nobody nobody
minds nobody minds seeing boobies i'm
just saying that it's like you've got
i've seen sleazier ones than this but
this is definitely like way more on the
end of like erotic
but there it's more violent i think than
your vice as a locked room so if that
kind of gives you an idea of where on
the spectrum it falls
so adveit finish plays uh mrs ward
actually her first name is julie her
strange vice is actually like a is
almost like a sata masochistic
it's essentially blood play uh she likes
to be
cut
uh that's you know blood kind of like
somebody one of the characters says
later on that it excites and repels her
like an equal measure so she has like an
erotic fixation on blood and on being
cut and on being kind of beat up a
little bit so i guess there's like a
little bit of a sadomasochistic thing
going on so at some point in the past uh
she had had a very volatile relationship
with this
very sinister dude named john
who lived in vienna
now i guess they had been going out for
a while he had indulged all of her
fantasies like he would cut her with
razors and things and she was like into
it but then after a while it became like
a really unhealthy like codependent kind
of relationship so she decided to leave
and i guess because this is the early
seventies y'all um she couldn't just
leave the relationship and just be like
okay i'm gonna go about my happy single
way now she had to marry somebody
because she thought that would like get
her away from
john so she marries this dude named neil
who's a diplomat now neil is not you
know he doesn't seem like real down with
the sexy times he's just kind of like a
stodgy dude he's not like old or
anything like that but he's just kind of
like seems a little straight laced a
little square and um you know so she
kind of married him for the stability
that type of thing
so at the beginning of the movie i guess
her and the diplomat husband have been
in some other city i think it's new york
but they're coming back to they're
coming back home they're coming back to
vienna after a certain amount of time
away
so when they get there though it seems
like jean
doesn't really want to
let julie go and keeps essentially like
stalking her not too bad but does seem
to be like kind of following around a
little bit he's always like sending her
bouquets of roses with like creepy notes
on them you know one of which says your
vice is a locked room
and only i have the key although that's
not exactly what it said it says your
vice is a locked room or locked from the
inside
and only i have the key so there's like
a couple extra words in there but i just
i thought i'd break that up but yeah so
so he's just been sending her roses and
kind of like bothering her and she's
kind of like
you know kind of over it at this point
now also go there's a lot going on in
this movie so let me just say that right
now there's a lot of there's a lot of
different factors and elements
so while she you know after she comes
back to vienna
it also so happens that there is a
killer running around vienna slicing up
young ladies uh you know he's got the
black gloves he's got the black coat
he's got all that all that stuff on and
he's slicing up uh ladies with a
straight razor
and then uh at some point she has this
best friend named carol
and carol
has this cousin
uh this sort of like sexy foxy
individual uh played by george hilton
who's also in a [ __ ] ton of uh giallo
movies he plays a guy named george so
julie meets george at a party uh at
which uh this is kind of where the where
the gratuitous nudity comes in because
it's like there's this party where she
meets george
and there's these two random women who
are just dancing at the party and
they're wearing these dresses and
everybody's like oh their dresses are
made of paper isn't that funny hahaha
like i said it's like you know early 70s
they kind of actually look more like
you know that material that they used to
make old like oven mitts out of like
that kind of silvery solar like quilty
type of stuff so it kind of looks like
that
but since somebody says oh the dresses
are made of paper so one of the guys is
like oh well i'm just gonna go tear the
dress off her because that's what you do
uh in the 70s and uh so she's like oh no
but then she's like oh okay whatever so
then she turns around to the other girl
rips her dress off and then they're
rolling around naked and everybody just
thinks it's hilarious so there's that
whole thing so like i said a very
gratuitous and very gratuitous duty but
like i said they gotta get you to watch
it somehow so you know what i mean
so
so at this party
julie meets george and uh she's kind of
like oh okay well i could get uh into
this so they basically have a little
flirtation whatever and uh not too long
goes by before she ends up uh [ __ ]
him so like i said she's just married
neil
the diplomat dude uh to get away from
her abusive ex-lover who also turned up
at the party by the way and she was just
like yeah [ __ ] this and she went out and
she left so now she's not only got neil
the husband who's like her safe haven
her stability or whatever but now she's
got like this other lover so like i said
these are like the three guys
that are kind of like
the you know the the usual suspects the
lineup like you usually have in a giallo
movie and like i said you also have this
random person this stranger
apparently that's running around killing
girls with a straight razor in vienna
who could be any one of the three
now as the movie goes on you're actually
pretty much led to believe
uh that it's john because he's like the
worst and he keeps stalking her and at
some point she gets a phone call
and it's basically blackmailing her
saying hey i saw you having sex with
george and i'm gonna tell neil about it
and you know unless you pay me like x
amount of money or whatever so she's
basically thinking that john is like
tormenting her all this time and you
know she's probably right in thinking
that because he has been tormenting her
like for a long time but if you know
anything about jala movies you know that
like the most likely person like the one
that they're trying to be like hey this
guy's like obviously a villain like he
does this this that and the other um you
know that that's probably not who it is
this one kind of plays with that a
little bit uh which i'll get into and
like i said it's just very very hard to
talk about this movie without spoiling
it so if you haven't seen it like go
watch it if you don't want to know like
who the killer is uh you know because
i'm probably going to spoil it because
the because like i said all the twists
and turns on this are just like crazy
so at that point she's kind of like she
says to her friend carol she's like hey
you know somebody's calling up like
blackmailing me and carol's like man
it's probably just john [ __ ] that dude
um she's like i'll go you know she's
supposed to meet him in this park or
whatever with the money and she's like
man i'll go i'm just gonna laugh in his
face you know we'll find out who it is
now you're kind of thinking well there
is also like a dude running around
killing people like killing women at
random and has killed like several
people over the course of the movie and
like cut them up and so you're like
maybe that's not the best idea and julie
does kind of try to talk her out of it
but carol's like man [ __ ] that you know
whatever carol is a very much and i feel
like there was a lot of characters like
this in these type of movies she's just
kind of like you know i just [ __ ]
everybody i don't care i don't want to
like i think she even has
i believe there was even the scene like
in her bathroom or in her bedroom or
something like that she even literally
has like a poster that says
literally sex without love on it like in
that kind of like hippie-ish looking pot
so it's like
pretty on the nose but yeah so that's
what she is she's just like yeah [ __ ]
that guy so i'm gonna go meet him and
i'll sort this out
that will not shock you to learn that
when carol goes to the park or wherever
uh to meet this dude she also ends up
getting killed and actually what is a
very good i really like because i guess
they really did shoot this in vienna
but i really like
this particular sequence like i really
like a lot of the uh shot compositions
in this uh you know the way that the
lighting is the way that um you know the
the characters are framed and like
things like that is actually like quite
stylish and quite cool not you know like
not not to the extent of like you know
dario argento or mario bob with like
those crazy colors or anything like that
it's much more
realistic but just i really like the use
of light and dark
and particularly in this one scene where
carol is being stalked through this park
and it's kind of getting later in the
day like it's right around sunset and
she's kind of going through these like
paths that are sort of like all these
hedges and stuff and uh you know being
stalked by somebody with like noise in
the background it's like really really
effective so carol gets killed at which
point julie goes to the cops and
basically says i'm pretty sure it's john
he's been calling me he's been sending
me roses he's being really creepy he
keeps turning up where i am
and it's like i don't know if it was him
that called me with the blackmailing
thing because whoever it was was
disguising their voice but she's like i
don't really see why it wouldn't have
been him because she had been you know
quite logically saying it's like well if
if i didn't know who they were then they
wouldn't have felt the need to disguise
their voice so it must be somebody i
know you know somebody must have known
that somebody me or carol or whoever was
going to be in this park of this day so
she has jean brought in for questioning
however jean has a has a like a rock
solid alibi like he had been seen like
in multiple other places like in this
other place like way far away and so
they know that it's not him
so then at this point uh julie goes back
home and then she goes to george and
she's basically like man i just like i
can't really take this anymore this is
[ __ ] crazy like my best friend's dead
like john is still [ __ ] being an
[ __ ] and it's like i don't really
know what to do and he's like well we'll
go away together at some point she's
like okay well i can't do that right now
it's like i want to find out what the
[ __ ] is going on who is this person
that's killing everybody all this other
kind of stuff at this point there's also
and there's another great stalking scene
where julie is coming home from the
police station and from meeting george
and everything and she's in the parking
garage of her uh apartment building
and there's somebody like the dude with
the straight razor is like stalking her
through this
garage and it's like like i said the
lighting is like really really cool in
there it's like all dark like these
pools of shadow but then like there's
just this one shaft of light across her
face and like i said she has like just
this great
face and she has like those great like
big false eyelashes and this big like
dark eyes and she just like looks she
does fear really well like her face
looks really good and uh so she she gets
stalked but she gets away and then she
gets up to her apartment and you know
neil is there her husband and he's just
kind of like okay well if this is john
i'm taking care of this [ __ ] right now
uh so he basically gets a gun and he's
like we're go come on we're going to his
house we're going to like [ __ ] him up
so then they go to his house and they
see that his little car parked out front
which you've seen this car it's like a
little black mg or something like that
and it's been like parked out front at
like a lot of the murder scenes which
like i said they're really like hitting
hard like maybe john is the killer
because he's such a douche and also he
has the same car that's been seen in the
area like at some of the other murders
so they're really trying to like
red-hairing this dude like big time but
then they go into jean's house
and they find him presumably dead in the
bathtub and it looks like a suicide like
the bathtub is full of blood he looks
like he's all dead and everything like
that and so at this point julie's just
like man [ __ ] this i really can't take
this [ __ ] anymore and it's just like
[ __ ] crazy so she goes to george
immediately and it's like please get me
out of here and he's like okay fine you
know i know this place in spain we'll
just go on a vacation we'll just forget
about all this for a while so she
basically just like
just leaves a note for her husband is
like bye
like takes off [ __ ] george so while
they're in spain though and this was
actually surprised me because i had
forgotten about this scene
while they're in spain uh the
straight razor killer attacks this
random girl she's like a uh like a like
a uh what do you call it like air
hostess or whatever uh and she's just
come back and she's come back to her
apartment and the guy's in there and
tries to kill her
but she fights back and ends up killing
him in her apartment and you end up
seeing his face and it's just some rando
right it's just like some guy that is
not even a character in the movie
so i love that they totally red herring
the guy going around being a straight
razor killer oh maybe it's john maybe
it's george maybe it's neil you know
maybe who knows like for a time i was
kind of thinking maybe it's neil because
he's like the less likely but then they
kind of show like this serial killer and
it's like a nobody it's nobody that
you've seen before it's just a random
dude
so julie while she's in spain like sees
it in the paper like in the you know
paper from the her home country or
wherever she was and she's like oh they
got him like you know one of the victims
got him it wasn't anybody i knew so
george is kind of like oh okay you know
everything's awesome now right yeah cool
you know because her thinking jean is
dead and now the straight razor killer
is dead so now like no worries she has
like nothing to worry about
but then uh she's basically like they're
out spearfishing her and george and then
you know they get kind of tired and
stuff and he's like okay well i'm gonna
go you know i'm gonna get a cab or
whatever and i'm gonna go like change
some money because they were out and
she's like okay well i'll go back to the
villa and like start making lunch or
whatever so she goes back to the villa
though and she sees like this weird [ __ ]
she sees like a
well at first before she runs back to
the villa she actually gets a uh a
bouquet of roses that's presumably from
john it has a note on it that says
something it's like oh hey like you know
uh the living can't give flowers to the
dead or now the dead can give flowers to
the living or something like that and
it's signed by him just this random kid
like comes up from the street and said
hey these are for you that guy over
there like told me to give them to you
and then she looks over there there's
nobody there and she's like okay what
the [ __ ] and then also somebody shoots
at her with a spear gun
like you know that used for spear
fishing like in the street and it's like
misses her and she's like wigging out so
she runs back to the villa and uh while
she's in there she sees like this weird
thing where it's like curtains like over
the um you know like shower curtain like
over the bathtub and it looks like
there's blood coming out from under the
bottom so she like has these flashbacks
to jean and everything so she's just
like wigging the [ __ ] out so then
[ __ ] uh george comes back and is like
what the hell is the matter with you and
she's just like oh my god it's like so
much [ __ ] freaky [ __ ] happened and
she was like in shock or whatever and so
he gets a doctor and then you know the
doctor is like yeah she's shocked and
like gives her sedative or whatever it's
like oh she'll be out for a while and
he's like well i'm gonna go you know to
this next town over and get like get a
specialist like a psychiatrist i guess
is what they're if they don't say that
but i guess that's what they're implying
so he's like i'm gonna get i gotta go
pick him up cause his car broken or
something so it's like you know there's
some excuse to like leave her alone in
the in the villa
and uh then he goes and checks out the
whole [ __ ] thing with the blood and
everything and it actually turned out
that it was just this rusty pipe like
behind the curtain like the shower
curtain the videos it was like dripping
this reddish looking [ __ ] like on the
floor and it did kind of look like blood
and he's like oh maybe she saw this and
it wigged her out but then george leaves
now while he's gone somebody busts into
the villa and she wakes up you know
somebody with a black glove like puts
the [ __ ] you know hand over her mouth
and turns out
surprise surprise it's john uh he
actually faked his death and followed
her to spain
and then he does this thing where he
drags her into the kitchen tapes up the
like tapes the windows shut and then he
like uh does the gas he pulls the little
gas main out and like turns the gas on
and then he does this really clever
thing and i was like man i'm gonna have
to like remember this little trick but
um i guess it would depend on what kind
of lock it was but i like that this kind
of played back into the whole your vice
as a locked room like locked from the
inside that you know said that in the
note what he does is that like i said he
tapes up the windows he puts the gas on
he lays her on the floor
and then he takes like an ice cube and
he puts it like in the
in the lock mechanism so then when he
closes the door and the ice melts it
closes the lock down so it looks like
she locked herself in there rather than
someone else being there so it would
look like a suicide so that's basically
what he does
so george comes back she's like
unconscious on the floor you know
there's he comes back with a doctor and
then they're like oh my god like we they
drag her out and they open the windows
and everything like that and the doctor
is basically like well
it's like well i'll try what she's not
breathing but i'll see what i can do and
then they kind of like smash cut to like
a next scene where you're led to believe
it's like the police station or the
coroner's office or something like that
and neil is there and george is there
and the guy is saying well you know the
doctor came and tried to save her but he
couldn't save her
so you know i'm really sorry about that
and then neil's getting all like shirty
with [ __ ] george it's like i blame
you for this like if you guys hadn't
come here this wouldn't have happened
she'd still be alive blah blah
and uh they're like yeah basically it
was a suicide you know we got a few days
like you know before we can release the
body but you know you guys are free to
go and then it turns out that there's
yet another twist not only is there a
twist of like [ __ ] john being still
alive
but the twist is that jean
george and neil were all working
together
and the dude that was like the rando
that was the was the straight razor
killer that dude didn't know them but
they each had their own kind of like
agenda and they thought well this will
be the best time to pull off said agenda
because there's this random murderer
running around and if certain people
turn up dead then it will be attributed
to that killer and we will be off
scot-free because no one will suspect us
so there was actually something to do
with that guy but they didn't know that
guy so all three of the dudes
all three of the dudes that this poor
woman knew
were conspiring against her
basically what the plot was let me see
if i can like come because it's a little
convoluted but what they were gonna do
so i guess carol who was you know the
friend like you know julie's friend who
was also george's cousin
i guess she
her and george were like the sole heirs
of this big fortune so george wanted to
get rid of her
so
neil wanted to get rid of his
wife
and then because she had like a bunch of
money too so this was all like for
insurance [ __ ] so what they would what
they did was they'd be like okay well
neil neil said well i'll kill carol
and you know they'll blame it on the
straight razor killer and then you kill
my wife and make it look like a suicide
and you know will and then john is kind
of involved somehow too like
i guess he was going to get a share of
the money also because he was going to
uh you know he like faked his death and
then there was this whole other
convoluted [ __ ] going on and uh you know
to kind of make her seem crazy so that
the suicide wouldn't come out of nowhere
i guess but then what they end up doing
is that george ends up double-crossing
john and shooting him like when they
were supposed to go to this money
exchange and then there's a whole thing
where him and neil get in this car and
there's like
you know explaining it's very like a
scooby-doo ending where they're like
explaining like how the plot worked to
each other even though presumably the
youtube but you know it's for the
benefit of the audience so there's like
oh that worked perfectly blah blah blah
happened and then blah blah blah
happened and that's it that's exactly
what was supposed to happen that type of
thing which i thought was very funny but
like i said it's kind of convoluted so
they had to explain it so the audience
would get it but then there's like this
really really funny scene where the two
of them are driving and like george even
though they've established that he's
like a really shitty driver i guess or
like a really reckless driver but him
and neil are just in the car just like
yucking their ass up just like oh we're
so [ __ ] clever and george is like
driving all over the road like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it's like hilarious so then
they're driving along and then they see
a woman walking down the side of the
road and neil's like uh hold up i'm
pretty sure that that was julie who's
supposedly dead because she supposedly
didn't survive the suicide
john like making it look like a suicide
so
you know george is kind of like man [ __ ]
that she's not alive it's just somebody
to look like her he's like nail's like
no seriously just like back up and we'll
find out and so they do back up and it
is like she turns around and it's julie
and it turns out
that uh the cops i guess had figured out
from carol being killed that they
figured out that that was a different
killer because even though it was still
straight razor like it was i don't know
if it was like left-handed right-handed
or if it was there was something
different about the mo so they figured
out that there was something so somebody
at the police station is like a [ __ ]
sherlock holmes [ __ ] and figured
out the whole convoluted plot so i guess
they made
both george and neal
think that julie was dead so they'd be
able to like show their ass so that's
basically how it works out so it's so
everything works out happily
you know uh the doctor kind of figured
out a lot of stuff the doctor that came
and you know saved her from the gas uh
dr arby i think his character's name was
so after that like when the cops start
coming because she's like walking and
then like all the cops are behind her
and they're just like oh [ __ ] were made
and then they try to take off and then
they go flying off a cliff and i was
like oh well that'll save the taxpayers
some money right there so that's nice
but uh but yeah so then she gets in a
car and the poor woman it's like she
gets in the car at the end and like dr
arby who is the guy like i said that
saved her and like figured everything
out and you know told everybody it's
like oh she's dead because we want like
to figure out what the plot is and
they're gonna
you know incriminate themselves if they
think that she's not around anymore so
he gets in the car with her at the end
and then he's just like smiles at her
and i'm like oh my god is this
[ __ ] gonna kill her now
because it's like she has like the worst
[ __ ] luck with men man it's like
every single man it's like her former
lover her current lover and her husband
were all like trying to conspire not
against her specifically but they were
because you know george was conspiring
against carol but they were after carol
was dead they were actually all
conspiring against her because i'm like
holy crap like now the doctors it
wouldn't honestly it wouldn't have
surprised me if at the very end the
doctor would have just like punched her
in the face because that's like
i like that's about the luck that this
poor woman has her just like drip off
cliff with her like well you know what i
mean that would have been like that
would have been like uh i don't know
that would have either been the worst or
the best tantic ever i can't figure out
which one it is so basically if you like
jealous movies if you like sergio
martino's other ones uh particularly if
you like jello movies that are kind of
more like the erotic end of the scale
this one is pretty violent but it's not
real gory you know because those are
kind of two different things um you know
you see people like cut up with but
nobody's like limbs get cut off or
there's not like big blood spray or
anything like that it's pretty like
grounded and realistic but honestly i
think
this out of all the sergio martino jello
movies that i've seen i think this is
probably like my second favorite one i
still think all the colors of the dark
is my favorite although i definitely
want to revisit that one because it's
been several years since i've seen it
but i remember really really liking that
one because that one was kind of had
like a weird
surrealist kind of vibe to it which this
one doesn't really have this one's like
a lot more realistic but the plot to
this one is kind of bat [ __ ] crazy um
you know and i i didn't guess i didn't
remember like that everybody was the
killer essentially which is also kind of
like bay of blood now that i'm thinking
about that mario baba movie where like
everyone's the killer but yeah so every
like all of the dudes in the movies
they're all killers so there's that but
uh so that's a little bit that's kind of
an original uh take on the genre i
suppose but yeah um if you're in a giant
you haven't seen this one this is kind
of like a pretty
you know i don't know if i'd say it's
like a classic classic but it's just
like one small little step down from a
classic one this is definitely one that
after you've seen like all the big heavy
hitter ones you know like deep red and
house with the laughing windows and
stuff like that uh this is definitely
one of the next ones that you should
take in because i really really like
this i like the look of it i really
liked all the acting in it and i really
liked just the crazy like convoluted
plot that i couldn't really guess where
it was going i think most people
probably wouldn't have guessed where it
was going because who the [ __ ] guess is
that every [ __ ] in the movie is a
killer you know so there's that whole
thing too but yeah uh check it out like
i said it's on shutter i'm pretty sure
it's also on to be as well as are a
bunch of other jala movies if you're you
know wanting to watch some
and check out some
examples of the genre then uh go check
them out and i will see you guys on the
next flickers of fear
bye